hey it's Joey and welcome to better
ideas if you're like most people you've
had a vision of your potential future
self the richer better looking better
groomed happier version of yourself have
you ever wondered if you can actually
you know be that person
I mean sure a lot of people they do
become rich they drive nice cars travel
the world and change the world most
other people though don't what's the
difference between people who succeed
and people who don't
and more importantly what are they doing
differently Jeff Olson the author of the
slight edge suggests that the road to
success is actually pretty
straightforward there is a surefire way
to achieve massive success and progress
in your life and it's not as hard as you
might think you're probably thinking of
course there's a way to get successful
like there's millions of self-help books
out there millions of business books
that talk about startup companies etc
etc that teach you how to be successful
in any given field but I'm telling you
right now that you can read all those
books you want but you're not gonna get
anywhere unless you understand the basic
principles explained in the slight edge
the slight edge is the idea that in
order to achieve success greatness or
any sort of improvement you don't really
need to take any sort of massive action
you don't need to take any giant leaps
in the right direction or do anything
remarkable at all but rather success is
the result of doing healthy unremarkable
relatively easy to do things every
single day over a long period of time
say you had a really rich uncle and he
says to you one day when he's feeling
really generous look John I'll give you
two options either a I give you a bag of
cash that has a million dollars I give
it to you tax-free you walk up that door
a millionaire option two is that I give
you one cent and I'll double that wealth
every single day for a month which
option would you choose you've probably
heard this before and you know that it's
a trick question
option one gives you 1 million dollars
an option 2 gives you 5 million three
hundred and sixty eight thousand seven
hundred and nine dollars and 12 cents
the same basic principle can be applied
to any area of self-improvement say
you're into bodybuilding sure you can
hit the gym super hard one day you know
just pounded out barbarically just go at
it
have the workout of your life come back
home have great amounts of protein and
have a good night's sleep you wake up
the next morning and you look in the
mirror you'll pretty much be the exact
same as you were before you worked out
in fact if you were to skip the gym that
day in the grand scheme of things it
wouldn't really make a difference at all
that's because you don't get to have
huge muscles by going to the gym harder
than everyone else the one day you're
motivated to go to the gym you get huge
muscles by showing up to the gym but
showing up every single day for a long
period of time this is true for every
single area of self-improvement want to
write a book you can't think of it in
terms of like suddenly massively having
this amazing inspiration to just crank
out 200 pages of brilliant literature
you have to think of it in terms of
writing half a page and then being done
for the day and the next morning when
you wake up you write the other half of
the page but you do that day in and day
out and by the end of the year you've
written 180 pages that's a book now that
may seem like a long time but that's how
success is built not by doing anything
tremendous but by chipping away at your
goals day in and day out and eventually
a year from now two years from now you
look and effortlessly you've made
something great so if you want to
achieve success in any given area of
your life break it down into a little
tiny simple action you can do every
single day but make sure you do it every
single day because it's relatively easy
to do but it's just as easy not to do
and doing it or not doing it is what
separates the successful people from the
not if you liked this video and want to
see me make more make sure to hit that
subscribe button down below also leave a
comment because I reply to pretty much
every comment 250 subscribers is when
I'm going to be giving away I don't know
how I'm gonna be giving away I'm sorry
so if you want to enter in I said in a
previous video that all you have to do
is subscribe but then I realized a lot
of people don't have like their you know
show subscription button on so I won't
be able to see the fact that they're
subscribed so if you want to enter
subscribe but also leave a comment
because then I'll be sorting through the
people who are also subscribed and have
left a comment I'm sweating catch you in
the next video